c'était des termes du type tu es tu es
le membre malade du corps qu'il faut
couper pour éviter la grand graine le
fruit pourri de la Coupe qu'il faut
enlever pour éviter de pourrir les
autres donc j'étais tout bonnement et
tout simplement la porte par laquelle le
diable rentrait à la maison enfin pour
eux si j'allais mal c'était parce que
j'étais
possédée l'âge de l'innocence certains
enfants connaissent déjà l'enfer il y a
quelques jours j'ai été frappé par un
chiffre en France en 2012 près de 15000
mineurs ont été victimes d'agression
sexuelle ou de viol Jérome
solvg leur histoire est similaire ils
n'auraient pas dû faire confiance à un
homme qu'il connaissait bien ils ont mis
des années à briser le silence depuis
ils veulent partager leurs histoires
pour éviter que d'autres enfants ne
connaissent leur cauchemar une femme et
un homme de courage deux exemples qui
prouvent que dans la vie la
reconstruction est
possible je m'appelle solvellie et j'ai
été victime d'un moine pédophile quand
j'étais plus
jeune je m'appelle Jérôme et j'étais
victime d'abus sexuel dans mon
enfance jérô
solg adultes à qui on a volé l'enfance à
9 ans ils ont subi les agressions
sexuelles répétées d'hommes
manipulateurs et se sont enfermés dans
le silence comme seule réponse à leur
calvaire lui a été la victime régulière
du meilleur ami de son père jusqu'à ses
15 ans
elle a été sous l'emprise d'un moine de
la Communauté des Béatitudes adulte ils
vont enfin
parler
[Musique]
comme toutes les fins de semaine sur les
hauteurs de Besançon Jérome bricole dans
sa maison aidé par son frère et son ami
David non ça c'est c'est pas celui on
avait av un bouquin aussi pour la
centrale en 2009 qu'il acheté cette
nouvelle maison et a entièrement rénovée
depuis une occupation qui lui permet à
42 ans de tourner la page de son passé
douloureux pendant que tu bricoles parce
que tu tu te concentres sur ce que tu
fais bah tu penses à rien à rien d'autre
que
[Musique]
ça et ça fait du bien de se vider la
tête si Jérôme a besoin de se vider la
tête c'est que pendant des années il
s'est tue et a enduré seul la
culpabilité d'une enfant brisé il a 9
ans lorsque le meilleur ami de son père
Michel l'emmène dans ses tournées pour
récupérer des animaux et les conduire à
l'abattoir contre une petite pièce mais
ces agréables balades sur les routes de
Lyonne vont se transformer en enfer un
jour de
1980 il avait l'habitude de s'arrêter
pour des besoins naturels voilà il a
fait le tour et il a ouvert la porte il
m'a demandé de l'accompagner de le
suivre je l'ai suivi dans les bois je
l'ai suivi comme un gamin s'enfonce dans
les bois c'est-à-dire que tu trouves un
bâton tu voilà tu tu Cagnes après après
les branches mortes voilà c'est c'est
une balade dans les bois il y a il y a
pas plus d'inquiétude à avoir que ça et
arriver à une bonne distance une
distance qui permettait de pas être vu
de la toute petite
route qui était à proximité il a déplié
une couverture et euh je l'ai vu faire
et d'un seul coup voilà il a il s'est
retourné il m'a pris il m'a déshabillé
c'est dire que j'ai pas compris ce qui
arrivé ça a été tellement
soudain puis en fait tout
tout tout mon corps s'est cristallisé et
tout ce qui se passait dans ma tête
s'est cristallisé tout s'est arrêté d'un
seul coup de ce jour-là il me reste pas
d'autres souvenir que l'instant où ça
s'est produit et le moment où je me suis
rhabillé pour le suivre et retourner
dans le camion et là le le petit enfant
que j'étais à l'époque était mort de
retour dans sa famille jérô ne trouve
pas les mots pour dénoncer l'amis de ses
parents j'ai essayé de faire comprendre
à mes parents commencer par ma maman
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas et je l'ai fait
en en refusant de d'accompagner Michel
lors de ces tourné c'està-dire que
lorsqu'il se proposait je trouvait
toujours quelque chose alors la première
des solutions c'était de prendre le
thermomètre puis à l'époque on avait
dans toutes les maisons des lampes à
incandescence donc je mettais le
thermomètre le long de la lampe à
incandescence et je faisais monter le
mercure pour pour me faire porter pâ ça
fonctionnait pendant un petit moment et
et malgré tout ça malgré le fait que je
recommence à chaque fois un jour ma
maman m'a dit il faut il faut que tu
réaccompagnes Michel il faut que tu tu
retournes en tourner avec lui Michel a
compris que jérô tentait de lui échapper
prêt à tout pour enfermer l'enfant dans
le silence il lui fait alors croire
qu'il entretient une relation adultère
avec sa mère je je me suis mis à en
vouloir à à ma maman parce que parce que
je comprenais pas qu'elle qu'elle puisse
s'amourcher d'un gars comme
ça je comprenais pas qu'elle puisse pas
voir et comprendre ce qui se passait et
à partir de là la relation qui était une
relation mèrefils et qui se passait bien
est
devenue sorte de guerre de ce moment-là
de ce jour-là tu tu comprends que tu
n'as plus de porte d'issu et tu peux
même pas en parler à ton papa parce que
il faudrait aller dire à ton papa que ta
maman elle a une relation avec son
meilleur copain donc dans ton entourage
il y a plus personne qui est à même de
pouvoir entendre et toi tu te retrouves
vraiment vraiment tout seul pris au
piège contraint au silence Jérôme subit
des agressions de plus en plus
régulières en plus des tournées Michel
abuse de lui lors des entraînement de
ping-pong et prend aussi l'habitude de
venir le chercher sur son trajet
quotidien pour aller au collège à 12 ans
le jeune garçon sombre dans le désespoir
je me renferme je parle beaucoup moins
j'ai pas d'amis les résultats scolaires
chutent très fortementf voilà c'est
c'est tout un ensemble qui fait que je
commence à découvrir les premières
drogues l'alcool enfin
c'est je suis résigné quoi je prends le
quotidien mais c'est un quotidien qui
qudien sen viei ce calvaire quasi
quotidien subir durant 6 années jusqu'à
ses 15 ans en
1986 je vais intégrer un centre de
formation en sonéloir devenir chauffeur
routier et je vais quitter Lyonne et en
quittant
Lyonne je vais plus voir G les
maltraitances vont s'arrêter je
rencontre une
fille Véronique et j'en tombe é
perdument amoureux donc le fait de
quitter Lyonne de tomber amoureux de de
quelqu ce qui n'était encore jamais
arrivé j'avais pas eu de petite amie
jusque là et
euh bien en fait je vais tout
occulter toutes ces annéesl et je vais
prendre je vais reprendre le cours
normal d'une
vie Carole Damiani vous êtes psychologue
jéromeme utilise un verbe important il
dit qu'il a occulté ce qu'il a vécu
est-ce que c'est quelque chose de de
fréquent chez les victimes de tel cice
alors on reconnaît chez les enfants qui
ont été victimes d'abus sexuel
effectivement ce qu'on appelle un temps
de latence c'est-à-dire un temps où
l'événement semble où l'ensemble des
événements semble oubliés et qui va
venir ressurgir soit l'adolescence soit
plus tard le temps de l'attence le plus
long que j'ai vu c'était 47 ans la
personne s'est souvenue 47 ans après de
ce qu'elle avait vécu c'est quelque
chose que qui peut être occulté à vie ou
ça ressurgit forcément à un moment ou un
autre on peut tout à fait vivre avec ce
temps de latence et ne jamais souvenir
de ce qui s'est passé parce que très
souvent en fait le souvenir va revenir à
la faveur d'un événement soit qui va
rappeler l'événement initial ou qui va
en être proche donc si on ne rencontre
pas ce type de situation l'enfant devenu
adulte peut tout à fait l'occulter
complètement mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a rien pour autant c'est une
façon de se protéger le temps de
l'attente c'est un refoulement
effectivement le refoulement est fait
pour se protéger le fait de ne pas
souvenir permet effectivement de faire
comme si rien ne s'était passé permet de
ne pas souffrir c'est une
protection abusé durant 6 ans par par le
meilleur ami de son père Jérôme a
occulté toutes ces années de calvaire en
partant de chez lui à 15 ans mais c'est
en revenant dans son village natal que
son passé va lui revenir en
[Musique]
mémoire en 1989 solveg à 9 ans ses
parents très croyants décident de tout
abandonner pour entrer dans la
communauté des Béatitudes situé dans la
mouvance du Renouveau
Charismatique quand mes par nous ont
annoncé que on allait on allait eménager
à la communauté j'ai pris j'ai pris
l'annonce avec une grande joie c'était
un petit peu le centre de loisirs nous
on était
entre enfants de mois après l'arrivée de
la famille de solveg dans la communauté
de Mortin dans la Manche pierreétienne
Albert le compositeur et chantre
respecter des Béatitudes s'installe à
son tour dans la
congrégation Pierre ettienne Albert a
intégré l'enseinble de la
famille de façon très rapide et et très
très intrusive puisque j'ai même le
souvenir que très rapidement il s'est
mis à appeler mon père papa et maman
donc c'était un voilà comme le le le le
grand frère de de de la famille les
heures familiales il est passé avec nous
donc il s'est très vite rapproché de moi
la petite fille se rêve un avenir de
religieuse et le moine va alors utiliser
cette vocation pour arriver à ses fins à
partir de 20h il montait dans ma chambre
et on il venait me voir en me disant que
voilà c'était pour me parler il est vite
arrivé sur les termes du type aimez-vous
les uns les
autres dieu est
amour et derrière l'amour il y a ajouté
des gestes lui m'expliquait que il
fallait que j'accepte que le Seigneur
m'envoie des gestes d'amour à travers
lui et que si je n'acceptais pas ces
gestes d'amour ça veut ça voulait dire
que je n'acceptais pas l'amour de
Dieu donc automatiquement je n'allais
pas aller voir mon père ou ma mère en
disant Dieu m'envoie des gestes d'amour
mais je les accepte pas c'était avouer
mon
péché de ne pas être une bonne
chrétienne de pas être une bonne
croyante le piège se referme sur
l'enfant solveg raconte son extrême
solitude certains
soirs il y a eu ces deux fois papa est
rentré papa est rentré dans la chambre
alors que que Pierre ettienne
était était sur mon lit papa a juste dit
t que aille dormir il a fermé la porte
et il a Essé pierreétienne là où il
était donc tout ce que me disait
pierreétienne était vrai c'était normal
à partir de là ça ne fait que que que
m'enfoncer un petit peu plus dans la
[Musique]
culpabilité rongé par le silence et la
honte solevg endure son calvaire pour
mon anniversaire ma maman m'avait offert
un
paravant avec avec des motifs chinois
sur le paravant et je me concentrais sur
les oiseaux du paravant c'était mon seul
échappatoire je me concentrais sur les
oiseaux jusqu'à ce qu'il quitte ma
chambre
c'était la seule façon que j'avais de
supporter ce qu'il faisait chaque soir
solve va subir de pierretienne Albert
jusqu'à ce que ses parents décident de
quitter Mortin pour un village du sud de
lasser de la vie en
communauté son sentiment de
honte chose de normal de fréquent
chez victimes d'abus sexuel ressentent
honte et culpabilité alors que l' lui ne
les vit pas c'est-à-dire que la victime
va prendre une partie de ce sentiment
qui lui
est souvent des abuseurs toi qui est
coupable c'est de ta faute si je vais en
prison ça sera à cause de toi donc la
victime finit par se persuader qu'elle
en est responsable et qu'elle en est
coupable quand on est enfant pourquoi
est-ce
qu'on
l'auteur intègre tellement bien quand
l'enfant est dans une relation
d'emprise la menace tel que le père ou
enfin l'agresseur le père le beau-père
l'oncle je ou le
grand-père là la menace est intériorisée
il est à l'intérieur de l'enfant en fait
la menace ça peut
être ta mère on dira que c'est toi de
toute façon donc cette menace est
intériorisé l'enfant ne parle pas
l'agression sexuelle c'est pas l'acte
sexuel d'amour qu'on peut retrouver
entre deux
partenaires
généralement dont la victime a honte de
parler c'est pour ça
que ond est-ce que ça arrive souvent que
les parents ne voient rien ou ne croi
pas leurs
enfants
ch par un
respons des Béatitudes alors qu'elle
avait 9 ans n'imagine pas qu'une fois
sorti de la
commun vont à leur tour un enfer
à 26 ans Jérôme revient dans Lyonne à
l'occasion de son service mil de passage
chez ses parents il va apprendre que sa
mère est gravement je rentre en fin
d'après-midi et je me rappelle qui était
plus proche qui vient vers moi et et là
elle dit c'est un cancer elle se met à
pleurer elle se
met ça été un chaos total ça m'a
retourné jourl
où enfermé très loin au fond de ma tête
à commencé
[Musique]
à 10 mois plus tard sa mère décède et
jusqu'en 2002 pour Jérôme ce sera la
descente aux
enfersir de son enfance me en mémoire il
se remet à boire à ce Dr et tombe
finalement profonde
briser
le je vais lui écrire un premier
courrier
ù dedans je lu je rappelle je rappelle
quelques faits je lui donne beaucoup
d'éléments pour qu' il ait aucun doute
sur la personne qui a écrit ces mots là
et pour autant je signe pas Jérôme
écrira encore deux lettres qui resteront
sans réponse après quel quelques nuits
sans sommeil Jérôme décide de révéler
son histoire aux 200 habitants de
Venouse son village natal il va alors
surprendre tout le monde en rédigeant un
tracte dénonçant publiquement son
[Musique]
agresseur enfant du pays aujourd'hui
exilé j'ai subi il y a 22 ans et pendant
plus de 5 ans les assauts de ce pervers
malin et habile il a usé et abuser de la
confiance de mes parents pour me violer
n'importe où et n'importe quand j'en
fais
je sais plus combien j'en ai fait j'ai
dû en faire 150 ou 200 copies j'ai fait
assez rapidement le tour du village pour
déposer tous les tractes dans les boîtes
aux lettres enfin Jérôme a parlé libéré
de ce poids il décide de porter plainte
le 2 décembre 2002 à la gendarmerie de
Villier
lechâtel l'audition après quelques
heures et au moment où il me raccompagne
à la sortie le gendarme me dit
que sans être complètement affirmatif
dit qu'il y a une loi qui pourrait faire
que les faits dont j'aiété victime sont
prescrits et donc je sors de la
gendarmerie et je retourne à la voiture
et et voilà je comprends que tout ce que
j'avais imaginé comme suite c'est-à-dire
une enquête immédiate peut-être même un
placement garde à vue assez rapide de
Michel Garnier et tout tout tombe à
l'eau c'est c'est le coup de ma su je
repars je repars travailler les jours
suivants et et je suis pas bien je suis
pas bien
ouis ça me quitte pas je je comprends
pas pourquoi je depuis tout petit on on
m'avait toujours dit que j'étais dans
dans une république
avec avec des droits qu'on était le pays
des droits de l'homme enfin voilà c'est
tu grandis dans une patrie comme ça et
et le jour où tu t'adresses à la justice
on voulant faire valoir tes droits on te
dit bah non vous en avez plus et
pourquoi vous en avez plus parce que à
un moment donné le le législateur a dit
pour ce type d'acte B on décide que au
bout de 10 ans il y a plus de recours
possible auprès de la justice c'est une
incompréhension totale et un sentiment
d'injustice profond ce ce sentiment
d'injustice là il
est il est invivable au quotidien il est
invivable rodolp Constantino vous êtes
avocat vous défendez de nombreuses
personnes victimes de pédophilie le
délai de prescription était de 10 ans a
près la majorité il est maintenant de 20
ans est-ce qu'il faudrait d'après vous
le le rallonger encore ce délai on
attendrait sans doute de moi que je
relais la parole de victime qui est
toujours une parole qui va dans le sens
de l'imprescriptibilité même pas
seulement du rallongement mais même de
l'imprescriptibilité mais ma position à
titre tout à fait personnel elle n'est
pas celle-là pour plusieurs raisons la
première est juridique il y a pas
d'imprescriptibilité pour les meurtres
ou les assassinats et si grave que soit
l'effet d'abus sexuel sur les mineurs je
crois pas que on puisse les soumettre à
un dispositif juridique qui soit plus
rude encore que celui d'un meurtre ou
d'un assassinat et puis enfin une raison
plus technique 20 années à comptter de
la majorité ça veut dire des enquêtes
parfois 30 ans 40 ans après les fait
eux-mêmes vous imaginez bien que
l'enquête est pour ainsi dire impossible
les preuves ont disparu ce sont des
dossiers qui sont extrêmement difficiles
dans il y a un aléa judiciaire
extrêmement
important et je crois que d'une certaine
manière rendre ces faitsl
imprescriptibles ce serait condamner
certaines victimes à être des victimes à
vie à 31 ans Jérôme a brisé le silence
trop tard pour la justice avant 2004 le
délai pour porter plainte n'est que de
10 ans après la majorité il décide alors
de mener seul son enquête l'objectif
retrouver une victime dont les faits ne
serait pas prescrit pour pouvoir faire
condamner Michel pendant 3 ans Jérôme va
retracer tout le parcours pédophile de
son
[Musique]
agresseur à 12 ans enfermé dans le
silence solveg va de plus en plus
mal ses parents attachés à la communauté
des Béatitudes ne la comprennent
toujours pas c'était des termes du type
tu es tu es
le membre malade du corps qu'il faut
couper pour éviter la gangraine le fruit
pourri de la Coupe qu'il faut enlever
pour éviter de pourrir les autres donc
j'étais tout bonnement et tout
simplement la porte par laquelle le
diable rentrait à la maison enfin pour
eux si j'allais mal c'était parce que
j'étais possédée voilà
j'étais donc ils ont pris la décision de
m'emmener voir un exorciste ça n'a rien
arrangé et soucis qui qui qui continuait
à me miner le silence qui continuait à
me miner a fait que je me suis retrouvé
en en
complètement détaché d'une certaine
manière de la famille euh j'avais j'y
trouvais plus ma
place solveg tente alors de mettre fin à
ses jours une fois rétabli ses parents
vont l'envoyer vos un psychiatre il
m'emmène chez un psychiatre qu'on avait
déjà vu une fois ou deux et ils disent
ils disent à ce psychiatre vous en
faites ce que vous voulez mais on en
veut plus chez
nous et de là j'ai été placée en hôpital
psychiatrique l'hôpital fait
immédiatement un signalement à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance et solveg est très
vite placé dans une famille d'accueil
mais là encore l'adolescente ne trouve
pas sa place j'ai commencé à rentrer en
conflit plus ou moins avec la la famille
d'accueil
où car j'avais le sentiment
que il m'empêchait de revenir faire mes
mes parents
euh alors que c'était ce que je
souhaitais le plus au monde c'était de
retrouver ma place dans la famille qui
était la mienne j'ai commencé à sécher
les cours à trouver du travail à partir
de là ben j'ai moi-même fait ma demande
d'émancipation puisque j'avais trouvé du
travail j'étais je pouvais être autonome
et ma demande d'émancipation a donc été
appuyée par mon père puisque c'était sa
volonté et donc à à l'âge de de 16 ans
je me suis retrouvé euh mineur émancipé
t que majeur et de là je n'ai plus de
nouvelles de mes parents pendant presque
une dizaine d'années à 16 ans solvg est
majeur aux yeux de la loi mais elle n'a
ni la maturité ni l'équilibre
psychologique pour s'assumer
seule je me suis mise en en ménage très
rapidement avec un homme qui avait
presque 20 ans plus que moi je suis
tombée enceinte j'ai eu mon premier
enfant quelques mois après la naissance
de mon fils je me suis séparée du père
de mon fils à peine sorti de
l'adolescence et déjà mère solveg part
alors dans une dérive qui durera 7 ans
j'ai pas de diplôme j'ai pas
d'expérience professionnelle j'ai pas
donc je fais des boulots de sererveuse
je fais des boulots de cuisinière je
fais des boulots de de animatrice de
soirée je pars je pars
vraiment tête baissée sur sur tout et
n'importe
quoi que ce soit professionnellement
parlant ou sentimentalement parlant quoi
donc
Carol Damiani la fragilité psychologique
des victimes est-elle une fatalité il y
a une fragilité psychologique évidente
mais qui va se retrouver dans dans dans
beaucoup de domaines et c'est difficile
d'imputer c'est-à-dire par exemple des
troubles anorexique ça vient de là elle
a des troubles alcooliques ça vient de
là elle a des troubles de la sexualité
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de de signne
ou de trouble dont on peut avoir la
certitude en disant c'est parce qu'elle
a été ou il a été abusé que il va se
comporter à l'âge adulte de cette faon
de cette façon et quand on a vécu cette
agression dans l'enfance on ne reproduit
pas forcément ce qu'on a vécu forth
heureusement il y a qu'une faible partie
d'entre eux qui vont reproduire ce
qu'ils ont vécu effectivement mais chez
des enfants particulièrement fragiles on
va avoir des identifications à
l'agresseur c'est-à-dire que l'enfant va
finir par faire sien le mode de penser
de l'agresseur et à son tour va agresser
d'autres
enfants rejeté par ses parents solveg
mère adolescente va passer 7 ans à se
chercher de petit boulot en petit boulot
et déménager une dizaine de fois une
errance qui l'amènera à l'autre bout du
monde au fil des recherches de jérô les
langues se délient dans le village et il
finit par découvrir que son agresseur a
fait d'autres
victimes et une des premières victimes
que je vais retrouver ça va être le
le fils de l'employeur de Michel G et
les faits le concernant sont également
prescrit au cœur de l'hiver 2003 après
un an d'enquête et face à cette nouvelle
impasse Jérôme décide de commettre
l'irréparable je prends je prends tous
les médicaments que je trouve
et je me réveille quelques jours plus
tard hospitalisé à
osser et réveillant au pied du lit il y
a il y a mon papa et quand je vois ça je
me dis c'est pas comme ça que ça doit
finir Jérôme réalise alors qu'il n'est
pas seul dans son combat judiciaire son
père qui le soutient va l'aider dans
toutes ses
démarches un petit
chou soutenu par ses proches jérô va se
consacrer uniquement à la traque de son
agresseur au détriment de sa vie et
sentiment Jérôme a eu beaucoup de
courage parce qu'il y en a plein
que
abandonné vu tout ce qu'il y avait à
faire
Jérôme même un gamin qui qui a beaucoup
de
mérite je veux pas dire je suis fier de
Jér mais si et les efforts vont finir
par payer puisqu'il finit par retrouver
une victime de son agresseur dont
lesffit ne tomb pas sous le coup de la
prescription le fait avoir un dépôt de
plainte avec des faits non prescrits ça
va
permettre la nomination d'un juge
d'instruction au parquet
doser un juge d'instruction qui va faire
un très bon travail en reprenant les
éléments que j'avais versés au
dossier préalablement et qui jusque là
n'avait pas été exploité et ça va
permettre de retrouver une autre victime
également Jérôme touche enfin au but du
combat de sa vie Michel va devoir
répondre de ses actes mais au dernier
moment son ur va réussir à se dérober à
la justice en juillet 2009 alors que on
était en bonne voie pour y aller au
procès mich va se
suicider il va s'alcooliser et se jeter
dans Lyonne la rivière
Lyonne et voilà le procès se soldera par
un non lieu faute d'accusé à la barre
une frustration insupportable pour
Jérôme comme pour les autres victimes ce
qui m'a fortement chagriné bah c'est le
le fait de pas avoir cette confrontation
le fait de pouvoir le le voir de lui
parler et et c'est aussi de savoir bah
que j'allais peut-être être obligé de
m'asseoir un peu plus
longtemps sur le divan de mapsie
quelques années supplémentaires plutôt
que d'avoir une une reconstruction plus
rapide grâce au
procès Jean-Pierre rosenveg vous êtes le
président du tribunal pour enfants de
bobini pour les victimes de pédophilie
c'est important procès pourquoi bah
parce que il va enfin être dit que le
coupable c'est l'autre et c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi d'avoir céder ou de ne pas
avoir sur résister c'est l'autre qui
j'allais dire a abusé de de sa force de
sa situation pour m'obliger à faire ceci
ou à faire cela euh le la justice c'est
un c'est un lieu de débat public c'est
une grande Agora où la vérité va être
dite l'un est le coupable et l'autre la
victime le coupable c'est le pédophile
la victime c'est l'enfant et il faut que
ça soit dit publiquement et que ça soit
acté et à la limite c'est ce que demande
la victimes elle demande pas des
dommages d'intérêt alors faute de procès
qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur proposer à ces
victimes moi je dis souvent aux gens
dans les victimes dans mon cabinet et au
tribunal vous avez pas porté pendant des
années j'ai été victime d'une agression
physique sexuelle et autrre et cetera
c'est donner une prime à l'agresseur
donc à un moment donné il faut savoir
dépasser ça prendre sur vous tourner la
page bien entendu qu'il s'agit pas
d'effacer mais s'agit de passer à
d'autres étapes la vie c'est une
construction permanente des gens ont
vécu des drames qu'ils ont su dépasser
l'homme et l'individu est capable de à
des ressources fantastiques on peut
avoir été violé et être
heureux c'est tout il y a un tas de gens
moi je rencontre un tas de gens
régulièrement qui me racontent que il y
a 20 ans il y a 30 ans ils ont vécu tel
ou tel truc bon bah bien entendu ils
auraient souhaité ne pas le vivre bien
évidemment il est h de question de
féliciter de donner une médaille à
l'agresseur mais il faut avoir une prime
il faut donner une prime à la
[Musique]
vie après 2 années à Mayotte solveg
rencontre un homme avec qui elle rentre
en France et aura deux
enfants pendant ces 10 ans elle essaie
d'oublier ses souffrances tant bien que
[Musique]
mal bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
onent cette affaire de pédophilie
singulière mise au jour dans une
communauté religieuse de laavyon un
ancien frère a été mis en examen il a
reconnu des attouchements sur une
cinquantaine d'enfants il est laissé en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire automne
2008 coup de tonner dans la communauté
des Béatitudes poussé par d'autres
prêtres pierre et tienne Albert se
dénoncent et avoue publiquement ses
agressions sexuelles sur plus de 50
mineurs une confession tardive après 30
ans de silence
pour solveg devant son écran de
télévision c'est le
choc à partir du moment où pierreétienne
a fait ses aveux tout remonte à la
surface des cauchemars des odeurs des
images des des des sensations enfin
c'est ce qui m'a ce qui m'a valu les les
deux les deux années donc 2008 2009 très
très très difficilees je décide de me
porter partie civile qu'en 2010 il me
faut quand même 2 ans pour de travail
sur moi-même pour euh pour refuser le
silence que me demandent à nouveau mes
parents et décider de de
de de sortir la tête de l'eau et le fait
d'accepter de parler à visage découvert
c'était rompre la honte euh et me mettre
vraiment dans un état d'esprit où je
n'ai pas à avoir honte de ce qu'on m'a
fait je n'ai pas avoir honte des
conséquences que cela a eu sur ma vie et
euh et je savais que à partir du moment
où euh où cette honte allait allait
s'effacer j'allais pouvoir relever la
tête et ça c'était quelque chose
d'important en 2011 le procès s'ouvre et
il permet de poursuivre pierre et tienne
Albert pour agression sur 38 mineurs
neuf d'entre elles seront parties
civiles on va énumérer chacun des faits
sur les victimes sur ce que
pierreétienne a fait aux
victimes même celles qui sont prescrites
euh et que bah on est face à
un un personnage qui est malade et qui a
toujours le même
système le même processus donc les les
faits le le le moyen d'arriver à ces
fins sont quasiment exactement les mêmes
donc à travers chaque histoire de
victime je revis à chaque fois ma propre
histoire un procès très dur à vivre
heureusement solvg peut alors compter
sur les conseils d'anne-mie sa voisine
et confidente
et c'est vrai qu'il a eu un côté même
pour les enfants ça a été dur quand même
c'est vrai que on a tous à un moment
donné besoin de de des conseils d'une
d'une maman et c'est c'est un petit peu
je sais que anne-mie me cachera jamais
rien elle elle a un franc parler si elle
estime que je fais les choses bien elle
me le dira si elle estime que je l'ai
fait pas bien elle me le dira donc c'est
vrai que cet amitié a beaucoup beaucoup
d'importance pour moi je pense qu'elle a
eu une force de caractère de s'en sortir
elle a été épulée par différentes
personnes différentes personnes qu'elle
a rencontré au cours de sa vie et je
pense que ça peut prouver à beaucoup de
femmes ou d'hommes qui subissent de
différentes agressions peuvent avoir un
cheminement s'ils sont bien épaulés
s'ils sont bien entourés ne serait-ce
que familial amical ou professionnel
finalement le 1er décembre 2011 après 3
jours de procès la justice condamne
pierreétienne Albert à 5 ans de prison
pour agression sexuelle sur mineur par
personne ayant
autorité ce soir pierreétienne Albert va
passer sa première nuit en prison le
verdict est tombé 5 ans d'emprisonnement
pour cet ancien moine des Béatitudes à
l'audience le père Albert avait demandé
des pardons à ses victimes mais pour
elle cette condamnation plus de 20 ans
après les faits n'efface rien j'ai la
sensation de sortir de 20 ans de prison
donc savoir que lui il y va que pour 5
c'est un peu difficile mais bon écoutez
mieux vaut ça que rien peu importe
presque la hauteur de la peine le tout
c'est que la justice a remis les choses
à leur place il était coupable il a été
condamné je commençais à pouvoir relever
les épaules et à dire voilà tout ce que
j'ai vécu tout ce que tout tout ce que
j'ai enduré je n'en suis pas responsable
on se redonne un petit peu la valeur
qu'on s'est enlevé pendant pendant des
années et on perd une partie de cette
honte et de cette
culpabilité même si réussir à la perte
totalement après c'est un autre travail
qui se fait qui se fait avec le temps
après c'est là on a on peut entamer à
partir de ce moment-l véritable travail
de
reconstruction Jean-Pierre rosenveg et
de votre point de vue de juge est-ce que
les peines contre les prédateurs sexuels
sont sont suffisantes aujourd'hui le but
n'est pas de punir le but c'est de faire
en sorte que ça se reproduise le moins
possible on n'est pas dans une stratégie
de vengeance c'est pas eu pour eu dans
pourd est-ce qu'il y a pas des
aménagements qu'on pourrait mettre en
place pour éviter notamment je pense à
la récidive euh si c'est la castration
chimique ce que demande d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de pédophiles pratique
aujourd'hui oui ça bien sûr ça se
pratique je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait les
traitements à la hauteur de de ce qui
serait souhaitable mais il y a
effectivement avec un accompagnement
parce qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait un
relâchement dans le dans la prise du
médicament mais un certain nombre de
pédophil revendique d'être malade et
disant je souffre je suis moi-même en
grande difficulté je me suis moi-même
livré je demande qu'on me soigne j'ai en
souvenir ce monsieur disant je suis
moi-même allé au commissariat en disant
si vous m'arrêtez pas en temps utille je
vais commettre une agression donc
certains font des appels du pied
demandent être soigné il y a une
technique de soin qui s'appelle la
castration chimique on pourrait la
pratiquer peut-être plus souvent qu' le
pratique mais est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourrait imposer que la
justice pourrait imposer c'est pas une
atteinte à l'intégrité physique qui soit
de la la personne qui soit insupportable
il y a une autre castration qui consiste
à mettre les gens 20 ou 30 ans en prison
je veux dire que c'est une privation de
liberté donc c'est un vrai débat qui
mériterait d'être posé d'une manière non
polémique et et pas à chaud à l'occasion
de telle ou telle affaire comme ça se
fait trop souvent en France où un drame
éclate le matin et le soir il faut qu'il
la décision la solution été
trouvée en 2005 Jérôme a créé
l'association Marie nausé en hommage à
sa mère une association qui vient en
aide au victime de pédophilie et tente
de prévenir la maltraitance sexuelle
régulièrement avec une vingtaine de
bénévoles actifs tous devenus des amis
proches il se réunissent à hie dans
Lyonne ce soir entouré de son père et de
son frère il évoque les actions à
venir c'est cette fois-ci encore une
fille qui été violé dans son enfance et
donc cette personne cherche de l'aide
elle a porté plainte donc je lui ai
proposer un rendez-vous dimanche matin
ce dimanche pour la voir discuter avec
et savoir comment nous on pourra lui
apporter une
aide des moments forts dont Jérôme a
encore besoin pour trouver la
sérénité quand j'étais enfant et puis
que ça m'est arrivé tout ça ben
j'imaginais pas que bah 30 ans plus tard
on pour en parler aussi facilement et
puis qu' retour de monde autour de moi
donc voilà ça ça fait chaud au cœur et
merci encore Christophe connaî Gérome
depuis 25 ans et c'est tout
naturellement que cet ami d'enfance
s'est impliqué dans
l'association depuis quelques années je
dirais 2 à 3 ans c'est un autre Jérôme
quoi il a envie de vivre il est il est
content il est entouré de de plein de
monde l'association c'était c'était une
façon pour se
pour prendre un peu de recul par rapport
à ce qui lui est arrivé hein ça c'est
sûr et aussi pour bah pour partager et
puis pour aider les
autres de retour chez lui à Besançon
Jérôme passe tous ses moments libres à
rénover sa nouvelle
[Musique]
maison ça faisait longtemps que que je
souhaitais habiter dans une maison et
une maison en bois voilà cétait toujours
un rêve de gamin d'avoir une cabane et
jusqu'en 2009 et parce que parce que
j'avais l'affaire judiciaire à traiter
donc j'avais très peu de temps à
consacré à une maison j'ai jamais acheté
et comme l'affaire judiciaire s'est
terminé en 2009 j'ai commencé à chercher
et j'ai acheté cette maison
[Musique]
2010 c'est une façon de retrouver une
estime de soi c'estàd que la réalisation
de de petites choses comme comme celle
d'aujourd'hui ou d'autres qui sont déjà
qui sont déjà faites sur ces dernières
années c'est à chaque fois se dire bah
voilà je suis capable de faire ça et et
de le faire bien alors que pendant très
longtemps ça a pas été le cas je portais
pas ce regard là sur moi en me disant ce
que tu fais s bien et é es capable de le
faire
voilà petit à petit après des années de
culpabilité Gérome retrouve une certaine
confiance en lui-même un premier pas
vers un avenir
apaisé
non non non non non quoi c'est bon la
pâte à meffine oui mais je sais que
c'est bon mais à chaque fois tu mets les
doigts toi qui et aprèsen fout partout à
33 ans maman comblée de qure enfants
solveg partage son temps entre Ren et
Paris où elle débute une carrière
artistique aujourd'hui elle a d'ailleurs
rendez-vous avec un photographe
professionnel pour un shooting et comme
une vraie modèle elle passe d'abord
entre les mains d'une maquilleuse
les premières photos avaient plus un
aspect thérapeutique c'était la
possibilité de de me voir différemment
que le regard que j'avais de moi sur
face à une glace donc petit à petit
c'est devenu c'est devenu une activité
annexe on va dire que j'aime beaucoup
c'est pas ce qui me permet de vivre en
principalement mais c'est c'est on
arrive plus dans un cadre professionnel
maintenant que dans un cadre personnel
ces photos solveg compte bien s'en
servir pour créer son book de comédienne
et décrocher peut-être un jour le rôle
de sa vie bien
celle-ci vraiment en train de penser ça
fait partie de des choses que j'aime
faire et je me donne le droit
aujourd'hui de réaliser des choses que
j'aime faire voilà si solveg est si à
l'aise devant l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est entre autres grâce au soutien de
Samuel son ami depuis 10 ans
jamais on tire un trait
sur sur ces drames maintenant elle a
appris à vivre avec et en apprenant à
vivre avec elle a réussi à se construire
et à s'épanouir à s'épanouir dans sa
féminité dans sa vie de femme euh voilà
elle n'était plus
seulement une mère elle ne elle
n'existait pas qu'au travers ce qu'elle
apporté aux autres mais elle a réussi à
trouver quelque chose pour elle le soir
dès qu'elle le peut solveg rejoint Émile
un ami pianiste et écrivain avec lui
elle répète un spectacle qu'ils vont
présenter en tournée dans toute la
Bretagne c'est pour ça il y a pas de M
renseigne toi et moi les cochons ils
sont contents ils sont pas plus que
méchant ce qu'on n'est pas tous en
dedans on REM la que toujours avant
voyons c'est euh bah c'est un un rêve
qui devient réalité et effectivement qui
fait partie de la reconstruction quand
quand du du haut de mes 33 ans me dire
que je peux finir par réaliser des rêves
même à 33 ans même après tout ça ça
permet de voir l'avenir de
façon plus dégagé les cochons ils sont
contents ils sont pas plus que méchants
qu'on pas
t
toujours
voyons
au fil des années ceux qui autrefois
étaient sous l'emprise de pédophile
manipulateur ont réussi à relever la
tête et à briser la barrière du
silence au lieu que ce soit que toute
cette douleur soit une
faiblesse j'ai décidé d'en faire une
force et donc aujourd'hui le regard que
j'ai sur mon parcours est plutôt positif
puisque je me dis que si je n'étais pas
pass par tout ça je ne Seris peut-être
certainement pas la femme que je suis
aujourd'hui cette histoire là ça ça m'a
beaucoup rapproché de ma famille de mon
papa
de mes frères de mes belles
sœurs de mes amis enfin voilà j'ai je
pense que le dernier élément ça sera de
de pouvoir avoir un jour une famille de
rencontrer quelqu'un de revivre
une belle histoire une grande histoire
et
d'avoir des
enfants